we've got breaking news from China where
the corona virus outbreak took a very
frightening turn overnight Chinese
health officials have adopted a new
testing method and the results are
dramatic the illness killed 254 people
in just one day that more than doubles
of previous daily record the total
number of people infected worldwide is
now more than 60 thousand an American
evacuated from the epicenter of the
outbreak who arrived in San Diego last
week has become the 14th coronavirus
case in the US and we're told more
people aboard a cruise ship have tested
positive for the virus Debora patta is
in Hong Kong Deborah how are they doing
good morning well more than 200 people
on that cruise ship are now infected
we're also learning that elderly
passengers with medical conditions will
be allowed to disembark tomorrow
provided they pass final health checks
but they will still be placed into a
government quarantine facility before
being released next week some passengers
on board however are battling with
isolation we're now into the second week
it seems an eternity cabin fever has set
in on the diamond princess the ship has
been on lockdown in Yokohama for more
than a week becoming a virtual incubator
for the disease it's starting to get to
a point where you can definitely feel
things getting tougher fear is also
proving to be as contagious as the virus
we have to cruise ships that have
experienced delayed port clearance the
MS waster dam was barred from four ports
across Asia over concerns about the
virus despite the fact that no cases
have been confirmed on board today it
found a home cambodia agreed to accept
the western dam cruise ship which has
been stranded at sea for several days
adding to those fears China reported a
record number of single day deaths and
new cases on Wednesday pathologists
professor john nichols was a prominent
researcher during the 2003 SARS outbreak
does that mean this outbreak is worse
than we think are we just not
understanding it
I think the second scenario is more
likely is that we're actually now
getting a better indication of what's
really happening in the community
authorities in China are now confirming
infections based on CT scans of patients
lungs
health officials previously depended on
lab tests which can take days to process
creating a backlog of untested cases
there's just so much we still don't know
right now you have so much pressure from
everybody saying you know we want
instant results we want something right
now everybody's just trying to keep one
step ahead of this fast evolving
situation here in Hong Kong they're
still battling with the virus and how to
deal with it but they're taking no
chances the Catholic Church today took
the unusual step of suspending public
Mass for at least two weeks Tony a lot
of people worried Debra thank you very
much